[Music]
[Music]
yeah what's up man how are you really
good man
glad to connect again thank you oh I
mean I'm getting to the point Lima in a
very sad place in my career I'm getting
so many emails so many 5-minute coffees
you know and it's scary because with
dailyvee I'm showing some of them which
as you can imagine only feeds the beast
even more right because if I'm sitting
there and I want to meet with me and I
see some guy I'm like I'm better than
that guy I'm gonna do it like yeah it's
really really tough and I Schultz is
right and and I'm so different like I
want to actually like I kind of you know
it's funny like I always wonder if like
my life will change and I'll just wake
up one day and not want to buy the Jets
but instead actually have that
five-minute coffee with everybody on
earth which is we don't really
interesting to me like like I would
really enjoy I mean I really would I
really would I really would problem is
it's not a good business and and I don't
want to monetize my audience so I'm
gonna shower yeah in Austin Texas first
day of a pretty intense week Austin to
uh to uh Boston tomorrow
connecting in Atlanta
and then speaking inbound huge event
then taking a red-eye that night to
London full day in London insane day
London at the office bunch of new
business meetings and then a jam session
with some clients then Thursday to
Lisbon Portugal to a speak at Web Summit
humongous event or the biggest if not
the biggest in Europe and fly to New
York connect and actually think I've
been overnight in New York which be
great could be home and go to the
Bahamas catch the boat that is a summit
at sea um really funny all my friends
are or hitting me up the last couple
weeks or like you're gonna inbound Web
Summit or summat it's seeing I'm like
all three they're like here right
because all of them are actually the
same three days one's impossible ones in
portugal ones and let's see
but that's how we also
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dude I'm so I'm so fired up we're doing
this it's gonna be good
oh my god really good three years in
this house serious glasses I like it
great we can do the podcast on the salt
dude look at that haircut we got to move
some furniture yeah he's all about
everything has to be approved done all
right
[Music]
so good to see your weight for muscles
to show up oh listen I'm running under
guns now what do we need we got more
stuff
I heard what do you need so I'm pretty
excited about this we need some
different kind of footage yeah
thanks brother do I get this d-roc this
is the good footage watch your head I'm
excited about the wine what are we
drinking tonight we got to look through
it we're doing a podcast we take them
all here cuz the sentence you start good
and just no distractions that's awesome
JB thanks for being rich thanks for
having me almost feel like we should we
should we should talk about why we're
here
it's kinda cool I totally agree I'm also
pumped because the setting is very cozy
for me this is basically it's like my
upbringing all this wine around me I'm
very excited and all the listeners
they've seen the picture so they know
they kind of get us they've got a sense
of what's going on here yeah it's
awesome and for all the people that are
listening for my world that came come
from the wine world this is a there's
some pretty legit [ __ ] here we curse
here right yeah oh good I don't know
yeah that's fine
um I'll curse for both of us um there's
a lot of great wine here so I'm excited
yeah we've got it we've got a wine
dinner tonight yeah one thing is that
two things please because I've watched a
lot of your stuff and you talked a lot
about process yes it for me like like I
talked about this [ __ ] - like processes
and we talked
we've talked about on this podcast a lot
with other people but the process of
that bill like that's the thing that's
all I ever cared about your preaching
brother
honestly I made a video that says that
is recorded that when I buy the Jets I'm
gonna deploy and it's gonna be a young
me gonna be old as [ __ ] when I buy it
and it's gonna say this is the worst day
of my life cuz the process is over a
hundred percent yeah I love the journey
so much as a kid with like girls in like
junior high in high school it was just
trying to get them to like me like I'm
so obsessed with the chase I wanted to
drink some wine okay me too that's the
load that's the one oh that's a
collaboration tip today let's do that oh
sure let's do that great so one so great
we have thirteen you said right all
right so we need three of each okay [ __ ]
I'm chicken now once I know sex do you
have another one you think oh yeah we
have to do 6:05 all right three of those
okay one duo for Darius so when I bought
this yeah I drank it and I was six or
seven it [ __ ] sucked
Oh for was it's a Oh for was a tricky
vintage or me of this now is killing the
Oh a lot of the Oh forth of Karen yeah
you know I was you know six or seven
weeks super terrible there's also time
awkward it was a disjointed vintage but
then it kind of come yet came together
okay all right now what is what is going
on here this is not lame bro what do you
mean it's not clean is how I do it
unwitting all this [ __ ] hanging around
that you mean this no this like you can
take the knife thing and cut it I don't
don't honey you by the way no no no you
don't understand if you if you weren't
here this is what I normally this is
honestly this is literally literally
literally how I open wine I have no time
and there's like that's it and like
there's no I'm not fancy and then I just
go like this and that's it like
this is not like some fancy restaurant
oh oh yeah we're making a vodka soda and
that's what means to us about the
process and simplicity in the wine us
talking about what we pistols because
you always hear oh you miss it what do
you you know right
that's you every day wake up you have a
rush I think I think I think that's the
beauty of what I've got yeah I think I
think I'm I don't I don't I think it
mine's a little bit more wide than that
kind of a mission but I kind of got that
man but like what I've seen is that was
the for me as I figured out liest
I'll be presenting I think so
[Music]
impressive this one's not gonna get that
first year I you oh there you go oh nice
work Wow
garyvee on this once or twice still got
some old tricks local vineyard and I
brought it back put it in my bike bag
and shipped it on the plane and when a
bike was coming out on the conveyor belt
all I was thinking was like please don't
be trippin red but I'm sure Brett
entrepreneur and by my definition that
means somebody likes losing meaning I
think of myself much more as a UFC
fighter than I think of a buck as a
boxer I like boxing more even though
that's not a popular thing to say but
but I also think that in boxing when you
get a loss it's like a scarlet letter
right like finish and UFC everybody has
losses that's just like part of the game
and I associate to that sport more as an
entrepreneur like there is no great
entrepreneur that doesn't have losses
it's not even the cliche [ __ ] of like
you learn from your losses [ __ ] that
it's just that it meant that you didn't
take chances I'm not here to be like you
learn from your losses I'm here like oh
you have no losses you didn't take any
risk which means you're on defense or
your passive which is even scarier
you're in the middle and almost what
she'd rather be defense than being stuck
in the middle so
[Music]
what up gang 5:00 a.m. LA Thanksgiving
began brewing anyway
real quick hope you guys got to check
out the full interview with Lance if you
didn't it's linked in here and what do
you guys think about the daily format
and they shorter we've got some in the
queue but we'll start up banging them
out in real time very shortly much-loved
best Thanksgiving ever
[Music]